ok estamos en el problema número 15 así
que venga dice la compañía de plomería
acn me manda un equipo de tres plomeros
a realizar un cierto trabajo ok vamos
bien estallido la compañía tiene cuatro
plomeros con experiencia y cuatro
plomeros aprendices y vamos a apuntar
eso la compañía tiene cuatro números con
experiencia con
ciencia ok mientras que por otra parte
tiene cuatro números que son aprendices
4 plomeros aprendices aprendices ok
4 - que son ayudantes y 4 con amplia
experiencia si el equipo debe de constar
de un plomero con experiencia y dos
aprendices cuántos posibles equipos
podemos formar ok este problema me gusta
fíjate bien tenemos un lugar dos lugares
tres lugares voy a mandar a tres
primeros a este trabajo muy importante y
de estos tres lugares uno de ellos tiene
que ver con lo menos con la experiencia
uno de ellos va a ser un plomero con
experiencia mientras que los otros dos
van a ser plomeros y aprendices este va
a ser plomero aprendiz y este va a ser
primero aprendiz ahora cuántos equipos
diferentes podemos armar si tendremos
cuatro plomeros con la experiencia y
cuatro plomeros ayudantes
ahora bien lo primero que te puedes dar
cuenta es que imagínate que los cuatro
plomeros con experiencia se llaman a bs
de
b c y d son los cuatro primeros que
tienen la experiencia de estos cuatro
plomeros primero vamos a elegir uno para
que vaya a este trabajo por lo tanto
tengo cuatro posibles números con
experiencia los cuales puedo elegir en
este primer lugar por lo tanto tengo
cuatro posibilidades en este lugar que
vaya el primero o el plomero b o el
primero se lo menos de ok esto para
empezar ahora imagínate que tenemos
cuatro aprendices que se llaman m m o p
m
n&p ese es el nombre de mis cuatro
aprendices en los cuatro primeros que
son aprendices bueno aquí tengo dos
lugares para ellos como los podemos
acomodar
bueno date cuenta que el primer lugar y
aquí es muy importante si aquí tenemos
el aprendiz número uno vamos a suponer
que le ponemos aprendiz 1 y aprendidos
si nosotros nos fijamos primero en el
aprendiz número 1 pues bueno este puede
ser tomado por m por n por
o por p tenemos cuatro posibles aprendiz
de plomero que podemos enviar por lo
tanto que cuatro posibilidades ahora si
de aquí mandamos algunos de estos
supongamos amén para el aprendiz número
dos ya no podemos mandar a m podemos
mandar solamente a n
o dicho de otra manera si nosotros nos
fijamos en el aprendiz número 2 entonces
solamente tenemos tres posibilidades
tres posibilidades si elegimos
cualquiera de estos para el aprendizaje
número uno para el aprendiz número dos
solamente vamos a tener tres
posibilidades porque uno ya está ocupado
por el aprendiz número uno ok y cuántos
esto bueno pues me quedaría cuatro por
cuatro por tres lo cuál es 4 por 4 16
por 3 es 30 más 18 48 de un 48 posibles
equipos que pueda formar con estos
cuatro plomeros con experiencia y con
estos cuatro plomeros aprendices de tal
manera que nos quede un plomero con la
experiencia y dos lo menos que sean
ayudantes o aprendices muy bien aquí
está el problema número 15 vayamos al
problema
16 déjame borrar esto y hablemos del
problema número 16 que tiene una figura
siguiente tengo dos círculos déjame
hacerlos de una vez por aquí tengo un
círculo parecido a este ok
más o menos así y después tengo otro
círculo parecido a este ok y tengo
coloreada el área que está en medio de
estos dos así que déjame tomar este
color para poner esta área coloreada
tengo esta área coloreada perfecto y que
me dice este problema me dice lo
siguiente la figura siguiente consiste
de dos círculos que tienen el mismo
centro es decir que ambos tienen el
mismo centro que está aquí este es mi
centro de estos dos círculos de este
pequeño y de este grande que por cierto
a eso se le conoce como que son círculos
concéntricos tienen el mismo centro y
además el área coloreada tiene un valor
de 64 centímetros
a dos de sesenta y cuatro centímetros
cuadrados esta área de aquí vale 64 mil
centímetros cuadrados perfecto que más
datos me dan el círculo pequeño tiene un
radio de 6 centímetros
el círculo pequeño tiene un radio de 6
centímetros vamos a ponerlos con este
color este ratio es de 6 centímetros
este radio valdés 6 centímetros y lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale el radio del
círculo más grande en centímetros lo que
estoy buscando es el radio del círculo
más grande es decir este radio de aquí
lo que quiero saber es este radio cuánto
vale en centímetros así que le voy a
poner el nombre de x atrás lo que voy es
x ahora antes de preguntarme por x
me gusta mucho la idea de pensar en
áreas así que sería bueno saber cuánto
vale esta área
cuánto vale esta área de aquí todo esto
todo esto y todo esto bueno si tenemos
un círculo con radio seis centímetros
es el área del círculo pequeño el área
del círculo pequeño a quien va a ser
igual bueno pues esto es pin por radio
pero el radio vale seis centímetros pi
por seis elevado al cuadrado pi por
radio al cuadrado es decir que el área
del círculo pequeño es igual a 36.000
centímetros cuadrados y bueno esto
porque porque ya sé que esta área de la
parte coloreada tiene el valor de 64
centímetros cuadrados pero también por
otra parte hace que el área de este
círculo pequeño es de 36 centímetros
cuadrados con esto ya puedo concluir que
el área de todo el círculo grandote el
área del círculo grande quién es bueno
pues es 36 pi centímetros cuadrados ya
esto le voy a sumar 64
centímetros cuadrados es decir el área
de todo el círculo grandote que tengo
aquí pues es el área de lo que tengo
coloreado más el área del círculo
pequeño que tengo aquí y cuando es esto
y 664 me da 100 100 centímetros
cuadrados perfecto ahora cuál es la
fórmula para sacar el área del círculo
grandote que tenemos aquí bueno pues la
fórmula es área área del círculo
grandote es igual a pim por el radio
pero el radio se llama x por equis
elevado al cuadrado esto por una parte
pero por otra parte yo sé que esto es lo
mismo que 100
centímetros cuadrados es justo lo que me
dan aquí arriba y ahora sí divido ambos
lados entre pil me va a quedar que x
cuadrada es igual a 100 centímetros
cuadrados o dicho de otra manera si sé
por raíces cuadradas de ambos lados de
esta igualdad me va a quedar que x es
igual a más menos la raíz cuadrada de
100 que es 10 y la raíz cuadrada de
centímetros cuadrados lo cual es
centímetros más menos 10 centímetros
pero pues estamos hablando de un radio y
el radio es una distancia por lo tanto
debe de ser positiva
tiene que ser igual a 10 centímetros y
esta es la solución de este problema el
radio del círculo grande es 10
centímetros porque nos dimos cuenta que
el área del círculo grande son 100
centímetros cuadrados sumando el área
coloreada de verde más el área coloreada
de blanco ya está problema número 16 y
vamos a buen tiempo así que vamos a
resolver el problema número 17 el
problema número 17 que dice sipe r&s son
tres números primos mayores que 2
p r y s son primos vamos a ponerle a son
primos y además todos estos son mayores
que 2 todos estos son mayores que 2 ok y
por otra parte n es igual a pp por r por
s eso también es importante n va a ser
igual ap por r por s ok cuántos factores
incluyendo a n iv a uno tiene en cuántos
factores tiene n incluyendo a n iv a uno
guau este problema me gusta bastante ha
sido de los problemas que más me gustan
porque es un problema donde hay que usar
la factorización en primos así que
pensemos un poco a qué te parece si
antes de verlo en una forma general
vamos a ponerles algunos datos a pr ya s
para ver cómo podemos descomponer en
primos a n es decir imagínate que te
vale un primo mayor que 2 a 3 ok
r vale otro primo mayor que 2 suponga
5 y este vale otro primo mayor que 2 que
no sea 3 de 5 ó 7
ok 7 es decir que n en este caso en que
p vale tres r vale cinco y esto va de 7
n valdría a 3 por 5 por 7 lo cuales 105
ok 105 a ver 5 por 3 es 15 15 por 7 76 y
105 perfecto ahora vamos a pensar en el
105 qué factores tienen 105 juguemos con
el 105 por aquí
tengo aquí al 105 y el 105 tiene como
factores bueno en primer lugar tiene
como factor el 105 ok es el primero que
se me ocurre pero además tiene como
factor al 1 ok
estos dos son de ley pero quién más es
factor de 105 bueno pues vamos a ver
cómo lo podemos descomponer el 105 es
exactamente lo mismo que quiere bueno
pues esto es tres tienen tercera la
tercera de 105 estrés y llevamos 1
5 15 535 ok 35 tiene quinta que 7 y 7
tiene séptima que es 1 ok por lo tanto
el 105 lo podemos ver y ya lo sabíamos
como 3 por 5 por 7 por lo tanto el 105
tiene también como factor al 3 tiene
también como factor al 7 y tiene también
como factor al 5 tiene como factor al 3
al 7 al 5 pero tendrá más factores pues
claro que si de ambiente y de juan
factor al 3 por 5 3 por 5 es 15 primero
nos tomamos a cada uno de los factores
que encontramos y ahora vamos a tomarlos
en parejas 3 por 5 es 15 por lo tanto 15
también es factor de 105 15 también es
factor de 105 quien más 5 por 7 35 35
también es factor de 105 es decir que el
35 también es uno de los factores quién
más
bueno pues 3 por ciento es 21 21 también
es un factor de 105 21 también es un
factor de 105 y existirá otro
nos tomamos 3 el 5 y el 7 y después
empezamos a tomarlos por pares 3 5 3 y 7
5 y 7 y ahora pues faltaría tomarnos 3
por 5 por 7 pero 3 por 5 por siete
jueces 105 entonces ya lo tenemos aquí y
además tenemos al 1 entonces podemos
concluir que todos los factores de 105
son 8 los factores factores de 105 son 8
son 8 los factores de 105 ahora eso
servirá para cualquier número en el que
se vea de esta forma pues qué te parece
si borramos esto de aquí y vamos a
recordar solamente que tenemos 8
factores de 105 aquí le voy a poner nos
salieron ocho factores vamos a ver si
llegamos a los mismos entonces déjame
borrar todo esto volvemos todo esto de
aquí a ok vamos a borrar todo esto de
aquí y vamos a hablar del número en el
número n es igual a pp por ere x es por
lo tanto qué factores pueden tener en
bueno n en primer lugar tiene como
factor a sí mismo entonces n es un
factor de n n también tienen como factor
a 1 todo un número tiene como factor a 1
por lo tanto ya tenemos aquí otro factor
pero n es lo mismo que p por r por s por
lo tanto también tiene como factor ap
también tiene como factor r y también
tiene como factor a es ok ya nos tomamos
a n
ya nos tomamos al 1 ya nos tomamos ap a
r ya s qué te parece si ahora nos
tomamos como factores a los padres es
decir pr también es un factor de n pr
también es un factor de n porque pr
divide a n
en ese cantidades iguales me los estoy
tomando por pares quien más a date
cuenta que ese ere ese también es un
factor de n porque yo puedo dividir a n
entre bs y me va a darte el resultado
para quien más también es factor de n
bueno pues ya nos tomamos pr rs falta
tomarnos p
por lo tanto p y ese también es un
factor de n p y ese también es un factor
de n porque si dividimos a n entre psm
va a dar del resultado r
guau esto tal vez sea un poco abstracto
pero pues date cuenta que ya tenemos
todos los factores ya tenemos el factor
a n al 1 y ese que son la descomposición
de números primos de n la factorización
de n y después nos agarramos los padres
pr
rs ps y ya no podemos tomarnos nada más
los tenemos individualmente como pares
además tenemos a los tres primos
multiplicados entre sí que sn y tenemos
al 1 por lo tanto los factores de n son
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 también son 8 los
factores de n por lo tanto podemos
concluir que cualquier número n que se
puede descomponer en tres números primos
tienen ocho factores y ya está tenemos
el resultado del problema número 17 y
también tenemos que ya se nos acabó el
tiempo así que no
en el siguiente vídeo en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a resolver el problema 18
que es el último de esta sección número
3 claro del examen número 5 así que
hasta la próxima